>> Donna: HILLARY CLINTON IS
ON A NEW BOOK TOUR AND SHE
HAS GONE AFTER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>>
WATCH THIS.
>> I BELIEVE HE KNOWS HE IS
ILLEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
HE KNOWS.
HE KNOWS THAT THERE WERE A
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT REASONS
WHY THE ELECTION TURNED OUT
THE WAY IT DID, AND I TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THOSE
PARTS OF IT THAT I SHOULD
AND SO I KNOW THAT HE KNOWS
THAT THIS WASN'T ON THE
LEVEL.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE WILL
EVER KNOW EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED.
SO, OF COURSE HE IS OBSESSED
WITH ME.
AND I BELIEVE THAT IT'S A
GUILTY CONSCIENCE IN SO MUCH
AS HE HAS A CONSCIENCE.
>> Donna: THE BOOK, "GUTSY
WOMEN" FAVORITE STORIES OF
COURAGE AND RESILIENCE
CHELSEA AND HILLARY CLINTON.
APPEARANCE IN BROOKLYN.
DO YOU WANT TO GO WITH ME.
>> Jesse: THAT'S GOING TO BE
A PAGE TURNER.
I CAN'T WAIT TO TEAR INTO
THAT.
>> Donna: OH MY GOSH.
>> Jesse: SHE IS CROOKED
PERSON AND FOR HER TO FINGER
TRUMP AS CROOKED IS COMPLETE
HYPOCRISY.
TALK ABOUT FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE IN AN ELECTION.
HOW ABOUT ALL THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
POURED INTO SECRETARY OF
STATE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT?
DID THAT OR THE $9 MILLION
SHE PAID A FOREIGN AGENT
CONTINUE TO INFLUENCE THE
LAST ELECTION CALLED THE
STEELE DOSSIER?
SHE IS A TOTAL JOKE AND SHE
IS A TOTAL HYPOCRITE.
BUT, SHE MAY SEE AN OPENING
BECAUSE BIDEN HASN'T
ANSWERED BEST QUESTIONS WHY,
BIDEN DID, YOUR BROTHER WIN
A BILLION-DOLLAR CONTRACT TO
BUILD HOMES IN IRAQ?
FROM NO EXPERIENCE?
OR HOW DID YOUR SON LEAVE
CHINA WITH A BILLION DOLLARS
ON AIR FORCE 2?
HASN'T ANSWERED THOSE
QUESTIONS.
HILLARY MIGHT BE SEEING AN
OPENING HERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Donna: I DO BELIEVE THAT
SHE HAS REPEAT YOU HADLY
CALLED OUT THE PRESIDENT ON
THINGS SHE DISAGREES WITH
HIM.
THIS IS A NEW LEVEL OF
ATTACK GOING AFTER HER
EMAILS AFTER ALL OF THE
MONTHS AND YEARS OF
INVESTIGATIONS.
REMEMBER NOW, REPUBLICANS
CONTROL THE HOUSE.
WE HAD THE BENGHAZI
INVESTIGATION.
WE HAD ALL KINDS OF
INVESTIGATIONS INTO HILLARY
CLINTON.
BUT I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
READING THIS BOOK SHE IS
TALKING ABOUT GUTSY WOMEN,
INCLUDING REPUBLICAN WOMEN
LIKE MARGARET SHANE SMITH.
GREG, WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> Greg: I ALWAYS LOVE A
BOOK ON FEMALE EMPOWERMENT.
I FIND BAD MESSAGE IT TOOK
TWO WOMEN TO WRITE IT.
>> OH, GOSH.
YOU ARE TERRIBLE.
>> Greg: I'M TERRIBLE.
COME ON.
YOU GO GIRL.
I FEEL LIKE HILLARY HAS ONLY
ONE WORLD TO LIVE IN AND SHE
HAS NOWHERE ELSE TO GO.
SHE IS LIKE A DRUNK
LOITERING OUTSIDE OF A BAR
WAITING FOR IT TO OPEN.
THAT BAR IS THE PRESIDENCY.
AND SHE MAY BE RIGHT.
SHE MAY BE RIGHT THAT WHEN
SHE IS LOOKING AT THIS
TERRAIN AND SEEING A BUNCH
OF LIKE SUPPORTING
CHARACTERS BUT NO MAIN LEAD
MY QUESTION IS, IF SHE DOES
ENTER.
SHE HAS GOT TO BE
CALCULATING THE RISK.
WHAT IF SHE ENTERS AND SHE
YOU POLLS LESS THAN JOE AND
LESS THAN LIZ?
THAT'S THE RISK OF BEING
HUMILIATED.
HOWEVER, SHE DOESN'T WANT
THAT FIRST LINE IN HER
OBITUARY TO BE I LOST TO
TRUMP.
>> Dana: TWICE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Donna: SHE LOST THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND
WOULDN'T POPULAR VOTE.
>> Greg: BY HER BOW
>> Greg: BY BER BOW
>> Greg: BY BYR BOW
>> Greg: BY BY PBOW
>> Greg: BY BY PERW
>> Greg: BY BY PER BOW LEE,
DONNA?
WHEN SHE SAYS THIS ELECTION
IS ILLEGITIMATE.
THAT IS HYPERBOLE.
ELECTIONS EXIST TO PREVENT
WAR.
THAT'S HOW -- WE DON'T HAVE
CIVIL WARS AND WE DON'T HAVE
COUPS.
WE HAVE ELECTIONS.
WHEN YOU START SAYING THESE
ELECTIONS DON'T MATTER, SHE
IS ACTUALLY PUSHING IT
TOWARDS CONFLICT, NOT
ANYBODY ELSE.
>> Dana: I WAS THINKING THAT
JUST IN LISTENING TO HER AND
HAVING YOU HEAR FOR YOUR
EXPERTISE ON THIS AND YOUR
EXPERIENCE.
THE LOSER OF THE ELECTION,
THE ONE WHO CONCEDES IS
USUALLY THE ONE THAT THEY
HAVE THE HEARTACHE.
THEY HAVE ALL OF THAT LOSS
THAT THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH.
AND, SO SOMEBODY LIKE AL
GORE, FOR EXAMPLE, AFTER THE
RECOUNT, HE DID NOT DO THIS
TYPE OF THING, TO SAY THAT
THE BUSH PRESIDENCY WAS
ILLEGITIMATE.
HE MOVED ON.
HE WENT AND MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA.
HE HAD PURSUITS IN
DOCUMENTARIES AND CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND I JUST WONDER ABOUT THE
DECISION TO CONSTANTLY
QUESTION THE LEGITIMACY OF
AN ELECTION AND HOW
DANGEROUS THAT IS.
>> Donna: I REMEMBER THAT
NIGHT WHEN AL GORE CALLED
AND SAID SHUT IT DOWN.
MEANING SHUT DOWN THE
CAMPAIGN AFTER THE SUPREME
COURT RULED.
WE ARE NOW IN A DIFFERENT
ERA WHERE ALL OF THIS
DISRUPTION THAT STARTED
YEARS AGO CONTINUES.
NOBODY WANTS TO CONCEDE
ANYMORE.
WE WANT TO CONTINUE THE NEXT
FIGHT.
AND THIS CAMPAIGN NOW IS
GOING TO BE ANOTHER EXERCISE
IN WHAT I CALL GUTTER
POLICY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
HILLARY WRITING A NEW BOOK
WITH HER DAUGHTER "GUTSY
WOMEN"?
>> I THINK IT'S WONDERFUL
ANY PROJECT WITH YOUR
MOTHER.
I DON'T HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
I THINK THAT'S FANTASTIC.
GUTTED GUT NEPOTISM.
>> Emily: BOOK TOUR IS
INTERESTING EVER SINCE THE
ELECTION WHEN HER
FAVORABILITY RATE PLUMMETED
LESS THAN FAVORABILITY RATE
ONE THIRD WITH INDEPENDENCE,
NONE WITH REPUBLICANS AND IT
WENT DOWN 11% WITH DEMOCRATS
AFTER THE ELECTION IN 2016
AND IT HAS NOT RISEN.
SO THIS BOOK TOUR,
ESPECIALLY SINCE SHE
CONTINUES RESIDING IN
VICTIMHOOD LAND, IT WON'T
DONER ANY FAVORS.
IT REMINDED ME OF JUST BEING
IN A SORORITY AGAIN WHERE
SHE WAS LIKE CLEARLY HE IS
OBSESSED WITH ME BUT DONALD
TRUMP IS HER ONE OBSESSION
WHERE SHE IS JUST ONE OF HIS
MANY TOPICS.
IT'S SO CLEAR.
>> Donna: SHE LIVES RENT
FREE IN DONALD TRUMP'S HEAD.
ONE I DO KNOW AND.
>> Jesse: DONALD TRUMP NEVER
LETS ANYBODY GO WITHOUT
PAYING RENT.
>> Donna: TRUE THAT WHAT I
LIKE ABOUT IT IS THAT SHE IS
GOING TO LIFT UP ONE OF
THESE UNKNOWN WOMEN.
MANY OF WHOM ARE NOT REALLY
KNOWN TO THE PUBLIC.